Wow
first thing I noticed is podiums for the
other guy over there feel like Billy
Barty up here kind of short down in this
area down here would love to be up here
but I'm down here this is very very
strange
ah I actually I was dating at Lincoln
Bedroom last night and I couldn't resist
getting on the phone and I called it the
Secret Service as the president feel at
Gonzaga and tonight in the nude my wife
when I were looking out on the lawn at
midnight these guys were fully unclothed
well it's good to have I've been
studying him since yesterday and I think
I've actually the way to do the
president is to start out with mr.
Rogers it's a beautiful day in the
neighborhood then you add a little John
Wayne here waygal let's go over the
ridge you put them together you got
George Herbert Walker Bush that's that
thing
now
thank you
tough crowd
um so we've had a lot of fun over the
years to get he actually he called me at
home which is a trip I got to tell you
to be on the phone I was doing an
interview with People magazine they said
hold for the President and your heart
just starts better something about hope
Dana hi you done Anna
and first you like come on who is this
well I thought you might come out you
know a little nostalgic thought you come
out been quite a year
add a little got a little nauseous there
in Tokyo should have seen the look on
the Prime Minister's face there Oh mr.
Bush you look like you're going to blow
chunk servant
the now I did use the hand the hand
there's a lot of hands with the
president you know a lot of different
gestures as you know the first one I
noticed was sort of the hitchhiker this
one those people down over there then
that's two six guns up here doing that
thing then the wandering index that
fella down there put them together and
then the staple it kind of go
so of course I completely exaggerated it
you know but in all fairness on Senate
live you know we do everyone we do good
Clint we do Ross Perot of course I did
do Ross Perot and here is the deal sing
man he's got one I almost shot like that
sing here it is now Christmas season in
this nice I love those Christmas songs
Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer now what
the hell is a red-nosed reindeer a
reindeer with a drinking problem I swear
not just a door here and sold all my
kids shoulders Marv I love Ross Perot to
press code does she love when he gets to
pepper what how do you have any evidence
what you're not listening to one word
I'm saying
ari I talk you want to sound bite is
that what you want you want a little
sound bite a little something to put in
your press story there's that what you
want
sing-sing is that what you're like huh
now the deficits eat the deficit is like
a crazy aunt down the basement knowing
it paying attention to her and she is
just getting on rare instinct here you
gets me I say take her out slap around
and hose her down well that was good not
as good as when he does me though I will
be doing things next year got a lot of
big plans going to challenge Bobby
Fischer for the World Chess Championship
gonna enter the triathlon competition
over there in Hawaii first you got to
swim then you ride that bike and then
you end up running 26.2 miles not going
to do it wouldn't be prudent at this
juncture that was the other one wouldn't
be prudent at this juncture that thing
doing that thing now I always did this
thing I always said that the president
goes in too bad it's bad but you only
did it once
I did for four years he didn't want so
uh I don't know do you want to come on
up
no I
I must say
thanks for having me thank you
we can do that now the other line okay I
just want to wish you all a Merry
Christmas and thank you very very much
and God bless you all and one knee lucky
I didn't hit him right on that
what
dare move my hands what I wanted to know
but I am very grateful to Dana and to
Paula for being here and Dan has given
me a lot of laughs he said to me on the
phone he sure you really want me to come
there and I said yeah and he said I hope
I've never crossed the line and I knew
exactly what he meant and as far as I'm
concerned he never has and the fact that
we can laugh at each other is a very
fundamental thing I'm not sure in
November November 4th that the
invitation would have gone out and Ben
had the same enthusiasm but we're
shifting gears and I think he's given us
a wonderful kickoff to what I hope will
be a joyous totally friendly very happy
somewhat nostalgic but Merry Christmas
for everybody in a few minutes Barbara
shows the press through this spectacular
house that we've been privileged to live
in for four years and we wanted to share
with some of you I wish we could have
had everybody the majesty of this place
which I hope many will get to see in
these various receptions and all but I
think there's something special seeing
it for the first time when it's just
just beginning and so let me take this
opportunity once again to thank Dana
Carvey for brightening our lives given
us a little joy and wish each and every
one of you a Merry Christmas and we can
never adequately say thanks for all
you've done for us
for your country and for the Bush family
thank you so much and God bless you